moi je connais la souffrance je sais ce
que c'est et je sais ce qu'est ce que
c'est que d'avoir mal au ventre ne pas
pouvoir remplir son frigo puisque je le
vis je le vis aussi avec mes patients
avec ce que j'ai soigné ce que j'ai
accompagné donc je sais au plus bas ce
que c'est que de morfler au quotidien je
sais ce que c'est que d'être handicapé à
tous les stades je sais ce que c'est que
de mourir je sais ce que c'est que les
difficultés et quand j'ai vu ces
millions d'euros et ses milliards ce
milliard s'accumuler j'ai eu mal au
ventre
de nouveau je me suis dit il ya un
malaise il ya un malaise parce que dans
notre société on souffre au quotidien
j'ai la voix qui tremble parce que c'est
la réalité parce que j'ai mal j'ai mal
de voir tout ce qui morfle et ça fait
cinq mois qu'on est dans la rue cinq
mois qu'on trime cinq mois que je m'en
prends plein la gueule que on n'arrête
pas de me dire que je suis une
opportuniste
en fait je m'en fous de tout ce qu'on
peut dire parce que ce qui compte pour
moi c'est que les autres s'en sortent
j'ai créé cette association pour les
familles monoparentales et j'ai eu
aucune promesse de dons alors que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut prendre en
compte et et c'est une démarche
personnelle mais aussi pour tous les
autres pour les personnes en situation
de handicap à qui on fait encore des
contrôles fiscaux alors qu'ils sont dans
la maladie de charcot ils sont en vente
il est et on vient les contrôles et
fiscalement moi ça me fait mal au coeur
ça me fait mal aux rockeurs aussi qui
est des personnes qui soient des donc
dans des maisons de retraite et qui
mange pour un euro par jour
ça me fait mal au coeur de voir comment
les gens sont traités dans ce pays ça me
fait mal au coeur de voir des mutilés ça
me fait mal au coeur de voir comment on
est traité dans ce pays alors ce soir je
vais vous demander si l'île d'er de
m'aider dans ma démarche puisque une
pierre ne vaut pas deux hommes on est
bien d'accord
l'humain avant tout je suis aussi
sapeur-pompier volontaire je donne de ma
personne au quotidien et j'aimerais que
ces personnes qui se sont proposés qui
se sont lancés qui ont tout à leur
honneur et en fait je le dis ce soir
c'est tout à leur honneur merci pour ces
dons j'aimerais qu'il fasse la démarche
de dire on double la mise
ce soir je vous aide demain je monte un
collectif d'associations et on reverse à
toutes les grosses associations et
restos du coeur le téléthon la lutte
contre le cancer
aidez-nous doubler cette mise vous avez
donné un milliard pour delapierre donné
2 milliards pour l'humain vous êtes
capable de stars vous avez de l'argent
vous ne l'avez pas chasser constructif
et serbie
[Applaudissements]